I'm pleased to introduce my company, Tokyo Technology.
Let me start off by giving a brief corporate overview, followed by a more thorough product review.
Our company was established in May of 1999. We just celebrated our 10th anniversary last month.
Our headquarters are located at Shibuya in Tokyo.
We also have a branch office in Osaka.
Our founder and CEO is Norio Matsuda.
He has more than 20 years of experience in this industry.
The total number of employees as of last month was 358.
As you can see from this chart, our revenues continue to grow.
We have grown our top line at a rate of 12% per year, since we started the business 10 years ago.
We are very proud of this achievement.
Sales in 2008 were 122 million dollars, slightly above our target of 120 million dollars.
Due to the current economic situation, this year will be very tough.
Even so, the first quarter of this year was not as bad as expected.
Sales were 27 million dollars, down 8 percent from first quarter 2008.